I want this I'll give you eight bucks
for it
no way the tag says twelve nine bucks
and I'll give you some free business
advice deal so what's the advice yes was
an original 1970s east-west calfskin
motorcycle jacket in perfect condition
know what you're worth cuz you just got
played so what the exactly is your
business you know how people flip houses
so I flip clothes
boom
dolla dolla bills y'all unless you want
the HPV bet a closing legs girl is
everywhere in the walls I could like
live doing this forever never have to
get another job again good
those shoes are ridiculous I know why
but I like you maybe you should pick up
a couple Red Bulls and some band-aids
cuz I'm gonna your generation is so
tough
low overhead steady demand high margins
you're killin
[Music]
once you lose eBay's trust it holds a
grudge I think the best thing to do
would be to move back home so I keep an
eye out no way I'm not selling stuffed
animals out of my bedroom start my own
site maybe it'll work maybe it won't but
it'll be mine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait
I'm so happy Oh hon is this about how
deep that buzz
[Music]
go ahead underestimate me I've got it
all figured out
[Music]
[Music]